welcome to podcast ville greetings uncle
Joey here welcome to the Church of
what's happening now it's brought to you
by on it the leader in supplements go to
alpha brain go for the newt the new mood
the shrimp export the shroom tech immune
they're all rock your [ __ ] world and
don't even get me started on the hemp
forest protein go down and I'm calm
right now in press in church bammo
and get 10% off delivered right to your
[ __ ] door and I also want to
give a shout out to your topia peanut
butter macaroon edibles they do the
trick that's all you [ __ ] need to
know kick that mealy
Wednesday August 16th you bad
[ __ ] let's kick this [ __ ]
melee Fantana
oh [ __ ]
he looks in your eyes are you [ __ ]
kidding me or what
oh [ __ ]
man when well when when when we here we
go Oh dick Italy
it's the church [ __ ] where those
[ __ ] Diaz uncle Joey letting
you [ __ ] know what time it is
we had a good time the other night with
Action Bronson my throat is still
[ __ ] saw my throat was sore when I
came back two examples Cisco and I
teamed up with that animal and between
the [ __ ] papers and the [ __ ] blunt
[ __ ] bong hits I lost my voice on
there but who gives a [ __ ] you lose it
you'll find it's like a [ __ ] nickel
you said Lisa ATS here I actually saw a
pretty interesting story about like
there's a voice coach who specializes in
scream rock and she was saying like they
were they had a few of the musicians on
saying how they were losing their voice
every show and this like teacher looking
all like if she looks like my mom is
teaching these people how to like
instead of straining it they're like
vibrating their vocal cords so they can
sing all the eloquent thing for tours
now well there's a whole you know think
that goes with that all those thing is
yeah I would like some type of coach and
they do warm-ups and they wrap their
throat with a [ __ ] scarf or my father
house and there's a bunch of [ __ ] you
got to do when you're a singer you know
when you're on tour and you're making
that type of paper and you know you
can't cancel shows
you could strain your [ __ ] throat you
shouldn't most ones people do whenever I
hear stuff like that whenever they say
like oh there's no cure for the cold but
then there's a show or a movie and they
you hear they get like egg that you can
get a shot like this stuff you can do to
get rid of the flu I just don't think
it's available to everyone like like if
you had a movie don't they have special
shots that will gaze Reuter I don't know
I figured I don't know give me like
vitamin D relay Estrada's in the house
here what's up ladies and gentlemen
looking trainer over at what's the place
fast twitch fast which Donna black house
okay so it's down a little beach
no we're down in we're right outside of
the South Bay Area we're in gardena so
right off the highway little hidden
warehouse it's a pro only facility so we
got all our UFC guys by the tour
Andersen's in there's two from time to
time still stopping his head in there
but man we're building up a dope team we
got um
whole underarmour facility there in the
back so we're making everything men back
to what he used to be building up a team
and not paying people to be there for
everybody who works there works their
ass off if it's a whole team like it's
all it's a whole different thing we're
trying to do we're trying to build like
the first real pro MMA team to where
everybody is like contributing and not
just you know paying people to be there
just bringing in their own training
partners like no we have our each
coaches we have our wrestling coach we
have our mortai coach and then we have
me doing strength and conditioning so
it's a how many strength and
conditioning guys you have just me right
now just you just me running the show
right now
and how many guys do you work with a day
Dave um fighters anywhere from five to
twelve of our guys we sponsor our guys
we take care of them we work with some
guys individually and then I have we're
open to the public as far as like
regular clients so executive clients I'm
training some of the USC football guys
things like that so it's the strength
and conditioning is open to everyone and
then the whole MMA side is our pro only
team so it's not like we have classes
going on or anything like that so it's
it's it's pretty secluded it's cool man
because there's some cool stuff that
goes on there that you know you don't
necessarily see at other gyms you know
what I mean like even today man just the
type of [ __ ] that's going on when those
animals throw down you got your ban
Kevin Casey Tony Ferguson all those
[ __ ] in there so is it hard for
a fighter to get a can't I go like if
there is a guy young up-and-coming
fighter right now how do you get into a
camp exactly so that's the thing we have
what we have we have an amateur program
to where people men like we make it
affordable for people man we make you
know like 100 150 bucks a month they
come in they wrestle they train with our
guys not during our procession but like
when our guys come in in 3 o'clock in
the afternoon they work with our coaches
and then they develop up but even our
Pro fighters we have it so that we're
giving them everything they get taking
care of strength training they got taken
care of on the mats that we have we have
therapy for them too so we get all that
[ __ ] they can carry 5 contracts all that
stuff so you have an acupuncturist down
there um we do we do now
somebody comes to you
work out hmm what's there between get in
shape and strength & Conditioning I mean
there's a big difference just the way
that we look at things we look at the
individual it's not just like oh I'm
training a football player I'm training
somebody like yourself so we do is we
put somebody through an evaluation we
put we get all their measurements other
bio measurements all that stuff and then
we have them go through a session we see
where they're strong where they're weak
what their goals are like what are you
actually trying to do are you trying to
be you know an NFL top lineman are you
trying to be a pitcher throwing 95 miles
an hour you're just a regular executive
client that you want to train at 6:00 in
the morning you have your own thing
going on so like we take what the
individual wants and what are the actual
like data of what's going on with their
body and whatnot and adjusting it to the
person so we take data-driven [ __ ] and
put it towards the actual the actual
program so it's not like oh this
person's doing that saying they're not
fitting into the last word program
I always know who saw that it work like
that but let's pretend I'm let me see
I'm trying to find the example for you
let's pretend I'm George him George
Mazda Bob I'm fighting Johny jiu-jitsu
what does the name Damien mind yeah ok
you don't look at him you're gonna look
at my strengths you know look at his
weaknesses uh-huh and you're gonna look
at my as weaknesses and try to
strengthen George's yeah so especially
for individual fighters for like a camp
for a specific type scenario like that
especially for some guys training for
the combine [ __ ] like that like yeah we
get it specifically for that so like if
we know Maya's gonna be more on the
jujitsu more stuff so we're gonna be
doing like bear cross with weighted vest
pushing the sled more more things
dragging him out putting him in more of
those situations that they're gonna be
dealing with in the actual fight yeah we
know so yeah so he was one of that yeah
yeah working up and strength and
conditioning I had last year to go to he
gun two years ago and he had a brown
belt and he'd say come work with me at
this gym just don't happened that the
[ __ ] gym was what's his name again
the guy from the UFC that the little
bald-headed dude he's on it he does a
football team yeah and this football to
college football jersey sweetheart of a
guy he owns the gym with the old
linebacker from the Chicago Bears uh-huh
Urlacher yeah oh so it's Brian Urlacher
hand fine announcer from the NFL he's a
little bald-headed guy I'm [ __ ] you
guys don't know especially you don't
know I'm talking about he does the UFC
with like on Saturdays he sits with them
and he's a little chubby bald with a
mustache and [ __ ] I forget what the
[ __ ] look I'm up before I shoot
myself I don't watch that team had that
much TV bro so that's the one thing I
hate glazed and breakable oh okay yeah I
know that's what he did
there's jiu-jitsu things you know the
guy was cool mm-hmm and then when they
told me he was broke and he wanted to
borrow $2,000 and he give me come on
girls a scam
yeah I go up there to work out he bring
me a contract to me decide not to join
unbreakable for a three-hour month oh my
dog you told me to come up here and [ __ ]
around with you when he didn't show up
and now you want me to I mean it was
just [ __ ] crazy but I was watching
what they were doing mm-hmm and it
[ __ ] blew my mind
like they had to do from the Giants and
they'll double back and was and I was
watching like as I was getting dressed
make him believe it was real slow
because fat people take it takes me like
10 minutes to put my belt around my
waist [ __ ] the beginning when I'm not
when I'm not old
when I'm cold like I throw it around I
can't reach at the end of the class I
could throw my hand all the way around
your belt on before you put the pants on
I don't put it through when you're
standing up that's like oh that's like a
jujitsu
oh yeah your jeans bo what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
so when I'm cold I can't wrap my arm
around my shoulder once I get one at the
end of class
you gotta see him like a [ __ ] doctor
was
but I would go in there and I'd watch
what they do and it was pretty
mind-boggling like how much you know in
the in the eighties I had a friend of
mine that was a strength and
conditioning coach from the Olympics and
I watched what they were doing in the
eighties they were doing great stuff hmm
but everybody was kind of doing the same
thing so if I came into the gym you came
into the gym and begi came into the gym
the work that was on the wall it wasn't
really specialized there's still a lot
of places like that man you'd be
surprised and now it's evolved like so
much you know I turn Leon to this guy
Dave oh that was [ __ ] great yes he
was a great dude kettle bell oh that's
what you guys were doing the kind of
miles of fire and you know he's just
really and I believe I'm like you listen
I like the guys that go to Boston
College and take kinesiology and they do
the other thing that you studied for
sports man no the other one well you
have to walk downstairs and see a
cadaver for breakfast yeah that's all
great but I like the guy that did it did
it and did it I've always been one of
those guys I like the School Book Guy
when I first met Lee first time I met
Lee the first as it then was we were
shooting something I only when I
Wilander let me some college throw it
away cuz I don't want it around here cuz
in that world I look like we're shooting
the same [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and it's so
weird how with what you guys do you know
I'm stoned
no I get it I get what you're saying
like it's um it's a whole it's a whole
different thing because at least at
least what what we try to do man it's
just it's just like that keep it to
yourself my thing is is we're trying to
blur the lines a little bit like show
people like there's not that much of a
difference between what where you think
you're at and where these high level
people aren't like you can get you can
get there too it doesn't take like well
I gotta show up at 6 a.m. and do all
this stuff like no you can do it at your
grams and at work and and there's steps
to it man there's people that you know
they work out once a week in this and
then they [ __ ] I'm sore but then they go
you know take a few days five six days
and then they go to work out again I'm
so sore I never get better I never get
better man it's like trying to start the
car every single time like it's never
gonna start up you got to keep it going
even if it's the most basic things like
when I tell people oh I'm sorry what
should I do go for a walk run walk on
the beach we live in California go first
what do something I got them something
when you saw the muscle needs blood you
gotta move it's amazing funny times I'm
sure and I go you know what I'm gonna do
something I go out the back and I swing
bathroom kettle bell do three sets of
cleans and I punch the bag of Sun when I
feel completely better sometimes my
knees feel tight I put [ __ ] ice on
them
yeah they feel a little better but I go
outside and kick the [ __ ] bag and it
loosens all this [ __ ] next thing I know
I'm walking tip top Magoo first hand I
believe in give him blood I've always I
learned that when I was 14 from
basketball these guys I know what an
injury is I know what injuries you know
what an injury is and you know the
dimension of injury and soreness there's
some soreness that Jesus Christ ready
for you know but it I you
when I first start working out Joey told
me like not to overdo it because a lot
of bigger people will do it get really
sore never go back I've never really
experienced that and I recently went to
a gym that I'm not a huge the guy's very
nice but I'm I'm starting to see why
people go and choose different trims
because it's a little bit what you're
talking about it's just like the list on
the wall he just kind of lets you do it
and then didn't really he adjusted some
things but I was doing he had the Rings
hanging from the wall I was doing poles
and I literally couldn't move my arms
for about four days yeah for sure now I
understand what you mean like the other
day I was I was a how to strengthen
conditioning session with Tony Ferguson
and we're just sitting there talking
shot man that guy's such a cerebral
fighter people don't understand like the
type of brain that that guy has like
whenever he retires fighting the mind of
that guy is a coach and just as an
individual is amazing how it breaks
things down and like that it's just
there's a lot that goes into being a
coach it's not just instructing somebody
a do this pick this up put this down is
a bruh - today hey what's up what's up
with that thing that I see walking a
little bit different bro I see you
arguing with your kids whatever it could
be any little thing and you just break
that person down the same way you would
for anything else and all of a sudden
their shoulders
actor telling you about all these
different things that they might have
not told you about before then they're
relaxing then they're actually doing
what you're telling them then they're
thinking about what they're doing and
it's a whole process man especially you
want somebody to get better and like
showing up to you every day and like
showing up 6:00 in the morning whatever
it is there's a whole process calling
people and just saying hey man how you
doing Bryce are you did this at this
event whatever especially now that we
have social media and half the people
are on their phones all the time there's
no excuse for you to say no I didn't see
that or not even just you know just come
and say something to somebody and just
like it changes their whole mentality
and attitude about coming to you and
then they actually you know listen to
what you're saying when you see the
results it's like oh [ __ ] I had that's
kind of yelling for people yeah I used
to walk that part nice to drop my wife
off I would walk and walk that part in
the mornings and I would see three or
four personal trainers and that's what
Lee was just saying I'm [ __ ] in
trainer Lee comes into me with him
[ __ ] Groupon I take a look at Lee I
know he's not John muscular if I walk in
there you don't look at me and go he's
not John Mafia let me before I even
throw him to the wolves
let me see what his capacities are let
me see what his capacities are I'm gonna
talk to him and tell him that if he does
this today I want to see him for sure on
Wednesday like what can I can you be
here Wednesday cuz I do not want you to
miss Wednesday for this reason and if
you saw come yeah I'm gonna take care of
you know and then people try to pull the
no I can't paint no no so so so she'll
work it out figure out what I think a
lot of people will join a gym and they
get to free they they tell them you get
three of the free training sessions they
don't even test the people to see what
they could do form listen bro I'm a
[ __ ] animal
I don't give a [ __ ] about anything
before I do anything and I've always
been like that I go to a professional I
don't go do me a favor when I shoot a
gun do me a favor you know either
Oh Oh Joey you're an [ __ ] you could
go on YouTube and learn that okay but
you might miss something that you know
especially when it comes to your body
especially when it comes to debt lifting
overhead presses or anything that you
know holy it's like we believe Lee and I
will go into a place and we're swinging
85 [ __ ] pound kettlebells
what is the purpose of that I left there
thinking one day what was the purpose of
that now guess what I can't go to Jeju
until Monday
I can't walk I can't do it the [ __ ]
you know let me tell you something
[ __ ] doing comedy it's just as hard
as working out that hour and stage of my
my girl feet a clamping to the ground
and shits moving through my hips this
times I go home and man I'm like what
the [ __ ] happened tonight I did two
[ __ ] shows that's what [ __ ]
happened this nights I go home bro take
a shower drink coffee and do it 30
seconds stretch while I watch Lord on it
yeah
because I know it's gonna make me feel
better the next day or even just laying
on the foam roll or anything anything
it's amazingly now I just don't go to
bed no more I take a shower and I take
cold water now [ __ ] pubs there's a
[ __ ] you know I started off warm
so you're not going in there like a
penguin and then as you're getting out
you [ __ ] reason every two minutes you
just keep it low low low and by the end
this is a [ __ ] ice or ice cubes are
coming out you don't even think about it
it's hitting your back we have our guys
do ice baths all the time especially
after training we have Kevin Casey and
another one of our guys go they grab the
ice throw it in there boom that's right
everybody at least nine minutes let's go
let's go and you just see all the guys
going like that man it's so important
people don't realize like how much just
even taking care of your body does for
your mental spirit for and just
everything that's going else on around
you like even when I first moved here so
I moved from Miami to LA about seven
months ago so that first whole
transition I I was a trainer over there
I was working out all the time I came
over here I'm like aa
jet lag it's not gonna bother me I'm
gonna be able to work out I'm gonna be
able to do all this boom hit me I was
just extremely tired just too much then
I stopped completely working out because
I'm like man I gotta rest it's just too
much and just from the one to two weeks
of just like trying to stop everything
in like ah let me get my stuff organized
just your mentality the way everything
goes you start to feel bad about
yourself and what sluggish yes is your
mind yeah just not not positive thoughts
man
the thing even like what you were saying
the other day just to go for a walk
to walk down the street to just like
breathe in the air here just get get
away from everything that you do every
single day and just be with yourself and
your own thoughts and just the most
simple thing from going to a walk can
turn you know your life into men this
walk feels good or whatever it is you
think about something boom you're going
somewhere else like these things get
your mind going - it's not just oh I'm
working out to work out nah man I'm
thinking I'm doing a baby shower where
they show a graph what happens to your
mind after 20 minutes of any type of
workout what happens to your mind how
the blood affects your mind what parts
of the brain it goes to well you know
number two I just I grew up on that
thought listen think about something you
are who you are who you are
we come from Cuban descent that means we
want a [ __ ] Island with no palm trees
for a long [ __ ] time
your grandparents took to the Sun with
no skin cancer SPF number eight all
that's [ __ ] Cubans define it
Cubans define it the ones that you see
the real dark they got no SPF on that
side of the island and the ones that are
real light from the one side to the
other side
it's like a [ __ ] graph like then when
you were kidding at the toaster toaster
whatever you want it and some Cuba's and
that's how you know and this is a joke
but it's it's the truth with some people
yeah Israel that's a that's a designated
desert but we're all from [ __ ] Russia
and the no Sun that's why I get spots in
my head they're like like this this
Israeli people who are from who like
growing up they're now in their tan like
the way they'll eat everyone goes in the
army they're badass but like there's
Jews there's a lot of dudes like me here
who just but this juice will work out
I'm just one of the indoor game I was
that was a coke fiend and when you do
coke nobody does coke outside so when
you tend to do coke after you do coke
that same
[ __ ] that you get on the coke stays you
don't want to go outside you're
depressed now it's the other side of the
coin now you don't want to go outside
and I learned from that like just going
outside going for a walk no matter how
bad I felt about the night before how
much I spent I didn't have the rent
money all that [ __ ] went away when I
went for the walk and I could put the
pieces together well I can make up my
mind and what my next move was from just
going on that walk yeah because one
minute you're thinking about one thing
and also in your mind takes you
somewhere else but you said something we
were just sitting early on the couches
which I'm a firm believer on I really am
like I just did it this last week
Becky called me she was Willy though it
was invisible you don't work on Sundays
had to work on Sundays but I did it for
like as soon as I was delayed on
Thursday I was like I'm not gonna do the
show right like I'm gonna force myself
to do it Sunday the mother plane got the
land it was think I was getting happier
there like I was like no I'm gonna force
myself to do it Sunday just to see what
it felt like and what happened nothing I
still came home Monday
I missed you Jitsu Monday cuz I got up
too early I got up at 5:00 to catch the
plane but I still worked out
I felt that jet lag and I go [ __ ] this
[ __ ] July and I went outside I
hit the bag for 20 oh I did three sets
of cleans with kettlebells I did the
[ __ ] swings with the bats and all
deal I did sit-ups and push-ups
I let the Sun hit my face and then the
last ten minutes I take my shirt off and
let the Sun make get the [ __ ] sweat
off my body and that's my SPF is the
[ __ ] fat sweat that comes out you
understand me
there's gotta be some [ __ ] coconut oil
or something there to [ __ ] block the
Sun have you ever liked these people who
are waking up it's like a lot of them
Navy SEALs wake up at 4 a.m. to work out
yeah is that I mean I'm not gonna say
it's bad I would never say it's bad but
is it like other benefits it just seems
like crazy to me to wake up at 4:00 a.m.
and be doing these crazy workouts I
think a lot of people do things like
that for the sole purpose of discipline
because if you really look at it I mean
man it's a whole different time in China
we all got 24 hours in the [ __ ] day
right 24 hours don't change it's a
different time in China it's a different
time in Portugal it's a different time
you know in Miami there's still [ __ ]
24 hours you can work out whenever you
want it's like it's just giving yourself
the actual breaks in between and that's
another thing people don't focus on rest
man rest in recovery a lot of people
just try to hop into a gym and try to do
all these crazy things hop in with the
gorillas and then like all of a sudden
oh I'm hurt on this and I'm man like
give yourself a rest you don't want to
make it to something to where you start
to hate it like that because you go so
hard and you put it as this big road no
as an adult you see that yeah as a 20
year old child oh what 25 year old child
yeah you do not see those yeah yeah I
see it when I ever since I joined up
Brett oh great
I've been there for like 18 months I see
people come in and I would giggle they
would look at me and go you only come
twice or three times a week that said I
go on the road man you know yeah I'm old
it takes me a little harder to recover
and they'll tell me how they came
nineteen days in a row 26 days in a row
and Becky what happens now or they leave
majors a big hefty a monster
well they end up you hold your we got a
lot of clients like that man just
because people end up like oh no I got
[ __ ] up at this place and then we
offer like you know recovery training or
whatnot so they come to us after that
and it's just like man like that you see
you see the people you know suffering
from whatever it is and it's like man no
it's not to be that's it that's all
that's I know yeah you're getting out of
here he's out of karate it was a white
kid there dad I didn't know but every
time he put his shirt on him he was
[ __ ] bruised like I told his wife was
being like that type and I said
something I don't mean to be nosy why
are you always bruised egos cuz on
Tuesdays and Thursdays I tell them when
I go to Thai town or for Hollywood and
Western on Hollywood Boulevard
two blocks down there's a tire there
used to be a tie center and then a place
that didn't massage and then a place
next to that was a restaurant
while behind the restaurant and fried on
Tuesdays and Thursdays the cooks would
beat the [ __ ] out of each other
tough luck beat the [ __ ] out of each
other and this white kid will go over
there because hopefully us from money at
least no no no boy high training with
the tree his legs were always [ __ ]
blistered bleeding his feet wall [ __ ]
up and I asked him what the [ __ ] is your
problem ligo's Tom Tom I need a sensei
you know cuz we were learning like tangu
no he's got some Tuesdays and Thursdays
I go over by the thighs to a Thai Fight
Club bag doors all chefs all the cooks
and the waitstaff and they had the trees
set up back there the tree whatever they
pick to get their Shenzhen bro he goes
it was full contact it was odd he would
come in with black eyes [ __ ] it was
on and I applauded him like I for a
couple weeks and there were nicer Tom in
class I know you know Jesus Christ I
love that you know at that time I was
400 pounds so I would admire anybody who
was working out but I said to him how
much you in the UFC or something why are
you doing this I mean he was like an
accountant it wasn't like he was working
security or he worked a ton at the
[ __ ] Roxy or he worked at The Comedy
Store and then he like one badass
security guy he was just any thought
about the use you know you're right I
know it's no walking around lumped up
yeah [ __ ] find it it's not worth you
and then with my fighters I'm still soon
yeah cuz especially some of the stuff
that they go through with the Train some
of the younger guys up-and-coming
they're trying to prove something in
training and you know you're dealing
with this UFC fight in front of you
you're one of the smaller guys in the
LFA or something you're trying to prove
a point and then you want to go do
strength training after and show out
there too so it's like man it's just
it's approaching it in a different way
man and just trying to change the game
for real that's why it's just I'm trying
to get it out there to as many people as
possible showing them you know what I do
what our program does and it's not it's
it's really not like a gimmick we're not
sitting there trying to advertise stuff
on Groupon it everybody come in man if
you know who we are you want to reach
out to us great like let's work you know
we always give people you know
trial session like that that's the first
thing we do just to see if it's
something that they actually want to do
or come in or if we see that we can work
together because like that man sometimes
you get people that come in and they
just you can tell from the get-go they
just look at you with a dead stare and
they're like oh I don't want to be here
some of these parents man unfortunately
that you you know you bring in a
six-year-old a seven-year-old kid and
the kids in there and the kid doesn't
want man the kid wants to be outside
playing around doing all these things
like and there's certain kids who do
want to be you know running clutching
drills but man it's all got its there's
there's all an approach to it there
can't just be one way of all this is
this is what it this is what it is this
is you know straight up a lot of people
since they like you said see it by the
books sometimes we get people you know
out of college they have master's
degrees they have all these things the
internships all this stuff and then you
put them there with a client and the
client even you can learn all the stuff
you want in the books and they're doing
the exercises I go I don't feel it here
what do you mean you don't feel it here
all of a sudden change it now you got to
change it now you got to talk to him
differently you've done it cuz if not
you look like the [ __ ] they're all I
don't know what I'm doing no you got you
got to know what you're doing you got to
realize that there's so many different
things man it's it's a whole different
game as you like
just to hit leave back before before I
got locked up I died rode my bicycle
everywhere and I hit the bag man lift
weights I just liked it and the ups do
without his ups do the delivered yoke
like body builder yoke but yoke that he
did push-ups and a well and I said to
him when he lifts he does I don't live
weights I sweat China why do you swim I
love to go with you he goes okay
I'll pick you up tomorrow 5:30 in the
morning go far in the [ __ ] morning
yeah he goes there's only two classes a
day six is 7:15
six or seven and I I put my amount then
I put my foot my mouthing okay make me
able to [ __ ] 5:30 to jump in that
cold pool but you know what though I
stuck with it for nine months until I
got locked up I got locked up on a
Monday and a Friday I was at the master
swimming program I even did a biathlon
like that's how much I [ __ ] life
swimming at that
but it wasn't just jumping in a pool she
hang on to the she's going in the
Olympics and she had been one of those
chicks that goes to Hawaii and with the
hammer chicks will he call those people
that they [ __ ] in 140 miles there's
triathletes she was the one that went to
the big ones all right
but yeah the big one so she would you
know I'll iron man iron man because you
come in and you could tell him hi I'm
Becky I was rollerskating I swear that's
great Becky jump in the [ __ ] pool and
you jump in and she goes me do me a
favor hold on to the wall and just kick
just kick until [ __ ] next Tuesday and
then talk to me she was a badass but you
know what brother the first time I got
the boy I jumped at it six she used one
before I'll [ __ ] yeah I jumped in I
started doing a bunch of these like
Johnny Olympian move three feet like I
was backwards I was sideways in the
water she's like okay coming hold on to
the wall just kick and she would make me
hold my legs a certain way and she jump
in the water and hold your feet a
certain way she was technical by the
book and you could go in there and a
week and a week she make you do laps or
two and you'd be like die and after one
week she jump in the [ __ ] water come
on this is how I want you to do it and
she would break it down for you Becky
that you can do 20 laps and not stop she
was a [ __ ] genius bro I never saw
anything like that no wasted movements
no wasted movement bring your way your
head turns to relax your muscles in your
neck I mean she would hold you the
details the details and then she would
have two three or four we should go okay
I want you to come Mondays Thursdays and
Saturdays why I could only come wizard
because Thursday I want to put you up
against this other guy because I mean
she was [ __ ] brilliant but to get
back the way you said Li let me tell you
something today in my world today I wish
I go to coach Joey on Wednesdays and
Mondays coach Joey and Alberto cranes is
creating killers over there
yeah I've seen those Arthur great
buddies huh he's creating killers over
there I can't do it I can't I need time
then when I wake up in the old days let
me tell you something they named them
late waking up I would smoke and joy
shrink the protein shake and get on my
beach cruiser and I'd ride over there
and the bike over the lane you can't
even believe this you know better way to
start the day leave I'd be out of there
by 7:00 I'd go to King's soup isn't
gonna big [ __ ] business before people
to said how bad sugar was I'm CUBAN dog
name that my freshly squeezed ah yeah ha
ha I would go buy a [ __ ] container
freshly squeezed orange juice and just
drink the whole thing ride my bicycle
home and Lee I would feel like I did
take over the world
you did the hardest part of your day
right there's the hardest part of my
mentally physically so I understand of
that part of it yeah I really enjoy plus
if you're fat [ __ ] like us and you lift
and do cardio it goes with us the rest
of the day mm-hmm so your metabolism is
lit and go and get cook it all [ __ ]
day so it helps with different things
for sure that's why people tell you when
you're waking up go for a walk mm-hmm go
for a brisk walk if you're fat [ __ ] go
for an hour walk that's it your
metabolism is on fire stay away from the
ring-dings don't something sodas and
it's all gonna work out for you you know
I'm saying it's that easy it's that easy
yeah no I was doing it was an 8 a.m.
class that I've been going to and I
liked it but I think it goes back to
what you're saying about knowing your
clients like I'm sure there's something
he has these warm-ups that like you're
supposed to do every class mm-hmm and
they all have special names I'm sure
there's some like fact like fit people
who know them and can just do them by
seeing someone do it he was having this
like 67 year old guy who's been there
for 3 years teaching me he's very nice
but uh I can't I need someone like you
someone who's worked out and knows how
to work out like with me to give you
that confidence just the beginning
feeling yeah at the beginning I'm the
same way bro yeah I can't have someone
show ya I'm the same [ __ ] way
not it's different when you approach
people like and even everything can you
can have something planned all
way up until that person walks through
the door and and you were talking about
it the other day on the podcast when
somebody walks through the door that's
why you have leave stop that you slow
them down a little bit so even through
the warm-up you kind of slow them down a
man what's up with your day what's up
with this what's up with that you start
to figure out a little bit more and man
like you you can really get to know
people and change people's lives in a
way that that you don't really realize
cause like I get clients that sometimes
actually gain ten pounds I used to be
super skinnier or just like you know a
mom that has had three kids that you
know wants to get surgery to take off
all all the skin and everything is going
through all this program and now you
know I have I have women that are going
in there
losing 1015 pounds and like taking
pigeon and it's it's way different to
tell somebody that you're just like this
is just the way I am I'm not drink any
[ __ ] protein like any T's fit T's I'm
not taking this pill like nah man it's
just I feel like I'm go to the gym I'm
just yeah like that man and people don't
realize like how how much that plays
into it and when people quit before
anything that that's not more problem
with our country that you know you go to
any type of martial art you going any
type of gym and if they look at the
percentages you know these gyms when
you're going then you sign up for the
other dick guitar when you going to
[ __ ] 24 hour early for our any of
these places or when you do that
three-year program yeah that dick gets
hard didn't you say some one of our
friends had like a seven year plan
somewhere yeah we got beat and they went
no come on
would you buy them when you buy the
memberships they go do you travel you
know like I don't know sometimes okay
well for an extra 200 hours you could
work out any 24-hour fitness in the
country she went to New York walked in
the elbows called the cops on me came
back and she couldn't get her money back
you know they have different [ __ ]
things yeah well they used to be a guy
oh sure he's still there okay Wilshire
and Fairfax you make a right and you go
down there there's a guy there that you
walk in smoke comes on the office he
comes out he's what you need though he's
a little Chinese guy
and he'll come out he'll train you and
Taekwondo but the first thing he'll look
at you know going you want to be my belt
yes he's like I make you black nothing
three and a half years with my limited
program only for you I do give me 15,000
brother there was a girl in my building
on Schrader that gave him a believer so
for three years
unfortunately I've seen that lay I
believe in man you tell me a lady that I
believe it Oprah 15,000 a year 15,000
for the three years up for him for the
accelerated black belt program man
there's people the thing is with our lay
like there's a lot of people that buy
into the hype that not there's a lot of
people to have money dog listen anyway I
know a guy
God rest his soul Mecca Foley he had a
client that would give him five miles an
hour
what and take him on the road with him
to shoot movies and I'm the movie sets
he was just playing 1500 fly hey Mack
Toffoli would call me everything go I do
I go what Mack what he's doing
and he'd be in his room smoking dope and
he'd tell me how he just trained such
and such for 45 minutes and that was it
he did six movies with him oh and did I
tell you he put him in the movie through
think I like the [ __ ] residuals in
the movie too well if you get your hands
down one of those guys the studio they
don't give a [ __ ] the studio paying you
500 and Bill him a thousand oh it's that
I mean so it's a scam yes Justin fortune
has ten studio rules like a saddest
thing I think yeah I've seen people take
without us without a facility without
anything I've seen people take cons down
to the beach no no equipment or anything
train them for 45 minutes a it's a
hundred bucks do you mean go we just ran
on in the same yeah father first of all
you have to figure out la that 40
percent or comedian who took his trainer
on the road things got bad quick that
trainer another rowing in the war he
took his trainer on the rope
but I'll tell you one thing didn't ever
want a grudge match
he had the train that he hired for the
Raging Bull now he was a grown man he
hired him with IANA college he was with
doing you were doing for the Jets didn't
ever hire them to train him from love
with the kid and said quit your job you
do every movie with me so I ate in the
morning
the guys excuse me
they run they do calisthenics one day
they they do push-ups they do rings he
said 70 you know I mean something he's
got him [ __ ] doing it's got to be a
match man that's why we have people come
in and do a preview session or whatever
it is first to like a let's see if your
before we even tell anybody about price
it don't even what are you what is it
cost bro just come in come in we'll
figure it out let me train you let's see
what are you looking for what do you
want what are you what are we trying to
do here and then after that we'll talk
about price because if not meant you're
gonna give yourself such a headache like
that charging somebody and and it
doesn't feel right man to be you know
you charge somebody something you know
they're looking for something else and
then it just it becomes this whole whole
thing man that guy downstairs from me
that finally joined the name because he
couldn't he was worthless and he tried
to go in as a seal and I think he's back
home I just saw yeah he was the guy who
the girls girl from that was safer they
had he that was his game he was just
juiced up he was a good-looking juice he
looked at the guy from sons Aniki Anna
Leon juice not the blonde good-looking
one the ball before the reeking kid
Oh what's his name the guy was there
yeah with the lightning rods in his head
he looked just like I'm only huge and
that guy I would see what he was doing
with people and I go what the [ __ ] is he
doing you know and that's why he ran out
of clients because he would run them the
first day like [ __ ] run them like
Bulls soon like you know so you got a
fat check that weighs 200 pounds you
can't run on like a bull you runner a
little bit you stretch her out talk to
her by the
and tell you see a Wednesday attend and
you just build her up little by little
but if that [ __ ] get saucy half these
people don't want to get sore anymore
huh
see once you go into that type of
clientele if you make them draw that's
not good no they just want to do it up
until this I kickbox Weaver day today I
love today
Rene exalt he's Cuban and oh god we
canoed and he was so great and Rene just
for that they'll give you a deuce in
Hollywood up in Hollywood these [ __ ]
actors and then go crazy like I was
tunnel astray and then Justin fortune
the actor that kept coming in and he
wouldn't fortune put him with somebody
finally we said [ __ ] that I want to box
with you oh [ __ ] Justin fortune started
working with him but John fortune told
400 an animal so I've been coming to
hours a day and one day told Justin put
me in the [ __ ] ring against one of
your pros and Justin goes brokes you're
an actor problem this is [ __ ]
you know I just have you throw jabs into
the air to make you feel good about you
don't get confused to do what they never
came back of course and that's what
happens huh but Justin knows it Justin
cuz I got him I had him for a [ __ ]
year give me in on your the day I ever
[ __ ] gives a [ __ ] I'm somewhere else
playing some other jerk off a thousand
now doctor him you some saying it's so
[ __ ] weird life is [ __ ] weird bro
huh it's like when you bartend I'm Ian
Lee we're talking about this one time
you know your friend hook show you
always had that friend that's the
hook-up hmm
Brian you go in there and then one day
he comes tea and goes Brock he'll get no
more tea on his wife is here what do you
do do i [ __ ] this blonde you crossed the
street you actually pay full price for
the drinks across the street this guy
just wants you to give him a 20 that's
it because you've been drinking there
for years
bumming cigarettes finally bro don't
leave me throw me a 20 and you get
insulted across the street and pay full
price and [ __ ] what you know I've known
a lot of
personal trainers with different types
of experiences and so we're now the guys
that knew I knew that we're still
successful other guys that were athletes
former athletes that had a kinesiology
degree or whatever the [ __ ] they had
from playing in college and now they
figured how to put it all together you
know I but I believe you guys like you
were saying that you play baseball so if
I come to you tomorrow and go let me
tell you something oh my my fastball is
88
how long will it take me to get to 94
which is uh which is uh pretty that a
bad goal no I'm coming to you at it's a
it's an achievable goal any four years
old and that's just releasing that's a
little bit of mechanics you work with me
on mechanics we do some [ __ ] we throw
some balls like I'm saying we spin
around yeah oh boy you know is that
possible like if I come for sure 100%
how much I have always been curious with
baseball how much of a difference could
I like if I came to you at 88 could you
get me to a hundred but uh I mean
there's a penny my age yeah well not so
much man like throwing 100 miles an hour
throwing a baseball is the fastest
movement a human body can do because of
just the angles that everything is going
on how hard I mean man what else can we
do that we put out with our own body to
100 miles an hour that sounds crazy you
know so something like that there's a
lot of structural things to to get to
100 but 94 like you were saying it's for
sure 100% possible because it's just
showing people how to use your body
because a lot of guys you just you throw
a ball your whole life and you don't
necessarily learn how to throw a 30
pound medicine ball into the wall have
to drive everything behind it with good
form and realize like [ __ ] man
I fiddle with my feet I don't just throw
in my arm here at the end I need to use
my feet I need to use this I need to use
that all of a sudden you start putting
all those little pieces together
that's one mile an hour by just
extending your ankle just a little bit
then you're using your hips a little bit
more that's two to three then you're put
all these pieces together then you start
feeling comfortable and you start
feeling a little cocky you start feeling
good then you start putting a little bit
more on it and then that's how that's
how it grows I went I was like that I
was a kid throwing 80
89 miles an hour by the time I was done
playing I had topped on 93 94
I'd had a elbow surgery Tommy John with
James Andrews the whole deal but at some
point like that I had to go from one
place to the other and it was just and
it was more more more of the training
more so than the throwing a lot of
people get fed into all I need to buy
this book with this many drills and this
guy's drills and that guy's drills man
straight baseball
how many ways is there to throw a
baseball like for real you know it's
more about teaching your body how to get
the most out of what you're doing to get
that result you know I love the elbow go
with baseball the elbow goes with a
change what pitching men like that
because our elbows just really meant to
extend back and forth like this that's
what we're made for us now once you
start getting into the rotation of
everything and people start leaning
behind and all that stuff it starts
putting strain on the elbow and like and
it's just it's it's a compounding thing
like when I tore my elbow it wasn't it
wasn't just like oh I threw drinking and
it popped or whatever like it was a
thing that happened gradually over time
and then one day it kind of kind of gave
out like man I was throwing it was cold
weather I was throwing I threw I was
throwing long toss and and I heard like
kind of like a crack like how when
you're back cracks like that and I was
like man that felt kind of weird and
then I threw the next one and it didn't
feel that good but I still was 88 to 90
that day so I'm like well nothing wrong
and then I go somewhere else to another
visit the next week and I was throwing
85-86 and I'm like [ __ ] ma'am I was kind
of sore what's wrong and then all of a
sudden I see you know I go get I pitched
the whole year like that with torn elbow
trying to rehab because people tell you
oh it's tendonitis it's this it's that
so I did everything to try to not to get
surgery and then I went to Andrews James
Andrews and man that guy's the best in
the world he's the one who did Drew
Brees his shoulder he does everybody
yeah Mariano Rivera all these guys you
always hear him on SportsCenter he's
like the the Tommy John yeah well he
always that's pretty silly you were
doing that in college yeah so I that was
my freshman year of cars that I got my
elbow surgery how do you pay do you have
to pay for that my school paper
got injured at school so how was her and
they believe that doctor well no we
picked that back to some somehow some
way you know how it is when you know the
right people I gotta move to no he can't
go to the doctor because this and that
all of a sudden next thing you know I go
up to James Andrews cost me $15 to see
the best doctor in the world like that
the guy comes in grabs your elbow
there's a bunch of things he doesn't
even look at the report he said hates
men he's got about like a 40% tear he's
got like three other doctors they're
just watching you're just riding down to
writing [ __ ] down looking at him looking
at you writing [ __ ] down he opens up the
paper Oh 45% terrible next thing you
know were there the next day in surgery
at his facility he even brought my
parents into the room set like that to
watch the surgery like on the screen and
everything opened up my elbow and like
that man I saw him he wanted me back two
weeks later and I was there with Sam
Bradford and another one in the NFL guys
is there chilling like badges hanging on
it's just me getting my thing done so
it's cool man it's a cool experience
like what we're talking about earlier
like just were sports takes you and all
the different experiences you see and
sometimes you need to go through like
those bad times to kind of like push you
to those points because if not man when
everything is just nice and breezy like
you don't get pushed anywhere sometimes
when people don't have that motivation
to go and they're just comfortable in
their thing like sometimes you got to
get put in a shitty situation like that
to get everything taken away from you I
thought I was going to college all this
[ __ ] you know scholarship LSU all this
stuff and I've seen you know your elbow
goes one now like what are you gonna do
you're gonna sit there and cry you're
gonna like you got to figure something
out and it's not to be you know like
that like like to the extreme of waking
up at 4:00 in the morning but like like
what we were talking about like my thing
for me that would get me over everything
was just going for a jog at night a
night everything's just dark you're
there with your own thoughts you're
thinking oh you made a pretty
interesting statement mmm you said that
pitching is what it's the only thing you
could do with your whole body
quickest the quickest quickest I can
crazy yeah
throwing throwing throwing a fastball
like that 100 miles an hour is the
fastest is the fastest thing a human
body part can move like what about those
things they prune the Olympics the
javelin very similar yeah but they're a
little bit heavier so like that at the
same thing with a full rise holds your
arm down so it actually it's safer to
throw football than it is a base
because your arms not going through the
speed that it would be in a short amount
of time because think about as soon as
you let it go you got a decelerate and
slow your arm down because if not your
arm pops out of socket that's why people
prony and then they slow their arm down
and that's why sometimes people when
they get the shoulder problems it's
mostly because either they're flying
open or when they they don't know how to
decelerate because they throw hard but
then you need the brakes for the car too
you know what I mean if you're [ __ ]
just got a car with an engine and no
brakes you [ __ ] - you [ __ ] you know so
that's why a lot of people mess up their
shoulders and things like that - there's
a lot that goes into it and I mean it's
just the same thing man it's Dave it's
seen in individual it's who pays
attention to the detail of the
individual a lot of people the thing is
with social media and with everything
like it's nice to get everything out to
everybody it's nice but when you start
to try to sell everything to everybody
and trying to just saw it as one general
program this and that then that's when
you start to show your ass sure yeah you
know because it's just that's it it is
what it is man it's so detailed when you
want to be the best like especially with
everybody now 94 is a good speed but
everybody in the meet a lot of people in
the major leagues throw you know 95 96
97 it's a it's a lot more common now so
now that levels getting that much more
Hartman I see kids like we were saying
seven years old eight years old doing
strength and conditioning you weren't
doing that as a kid I wasn't doing that
as a kid when I started doing bands as a
sophomore people were laughs well you
weren't supposed to yeah until you got
here on your dick you weren't supposed
to touch [ __ ] way to touch away to
gaze on your dick you can live way
through [ __ ] like that I had a high
weights my mom wouldn't let me live
she's like with you if I can get hair on
your dick then you can lift weights
because try to take those sliding doors
mm-hm do you ever take a wooden sliding
door you like that the closet if you
take that and put it on two chairs you
got a bench there you go yeah I got
myself some dumbbells that would do the
[ __ ] things downstairs an item it
should go out [ __ ] you lifting weights
with the closet you son of a [ __ ] you
finish it out you know saying but no I I
didn't know if it worked like that how
about for punching yeah I can get you
know I'm not saying me I'm saying the
fighter could punch harder with
100% same thing you're learning to drive
through your whole body there's one
thing just tapping somebody and then
driving through somebody and then being
able to do it consistently - it's great
if you can do it for the first round but
then once you start to get into those
later rounds and you still have that cat
you still have that preciseness that
still that same edge it's a whole
different game you know because people
like men we train all this time
especially for the fighters the same
thing I tell them you guys are training
from most five minutes like four
championship fights is five minute
rounds you're training for a five minute
opportunity because you don't know if
you're gonna get past the first round
you're assuming you think you're that
[ __ ] good for real the guy you're
fighting is just as good as you are so
you got a train like that like these are
I'm only getting these five minutes I
better [ __ ] maximize everything I'm
doing to that so the same thing driving
through everything you're doing
activating just different things
depending on who same thing what kind of
camp you're going through where your
meals are at one thing that I really try
to focus on my fighters is having to
avoid a weight cut a lot of people like
the old school mentality is all you
don't want to really be walking around
that way you don't want to be why not
why do you have to cut 26 pounds to get
to where you're fighting and then all of
a sudden like it's just it's a very old
way of thinking you know I don't
understand why it's not done at the
beginning of the training camp hmm so he
doesn't go in there I just never
understood that so the guy doesn't walk
in there sucked out to death yeah for
sure I at least try to get if if
somebody's like really overweight with
me I try to at least get two pounds a
week and with our guys a lot of people
like to do four we training camps we
like to do six and just like that like
that like those first two weeks we focus
a lot more on the strength and
conditioning and more wrestling like
grappling stuff to get them sweating to
get all that [ __ ] out of them to get
whatever if they had you know some some
guys like to take a long break after
fights so the all this terrible food
which is another thing to these fighters
starve themselves so much and then all
of a sudden when they're done with their
fight they're so happy they're
celebrating they got all this money now
and then they do eat all this [ __ ] food
for two weeks and you just went you know
back a step and then you know it's just
it's a constant thing so that's that's
why we're there we're trying to create
the first like real pro team to change
the game man to show people that [ __ ]
man it's not just a bunch of people
hopping in a room fighting punching each
other there's a whole process to this
that's why Black House has been around
for so long that's why you know they
partnered up with the Under Armour
company in with us now like there's a
whole there's a whole thing to it like I
didn't just how many black college gyms
are there Oh around around the world
I think there's seven there's here's the
headquarters we have one in Redondo
Beach - that's open for classes and
whatnot then we have one in Miami Beach
we have one in Brazil one in Mexico so
they're they're kind of around
everywhere but this is our main one -
like it's only the pro guys so that's
why it's a whole different level when
you walk in there and on any given day
there's for UFC guys three Bellator guys
and then three guys coming up just you
know hunters coming in from Brazil
because we bring in we have guys coming
in everywhere because like even through
my training through my Instagram I wanna
have guys hitting me up how do I train
that black house like bro I'm just a
strength and conditioning guy yeah but
how do I get in there because like
people know the name they know I
understand they know Liotta they know
you know RDAs training with us now Tony
Ferguson you know Alan Jobe and Kevin
Casey like the names that are in there
legit guys so you go in there you're
finding training partners from every
weight class from every different
organization and there's no there's no
[ __ ] there's no oh I'm just gonna
sit out this run know they'll call your
ass hell hey let's go ask you something
so somebody's getting ready for a fight
mm-hmm and there's six weeks away how
many days a week do they do the strength
and conditioning classes three three out
of the six three okay and then it's like
I'm solid three same workout two three
days no different no yeah yeah it's a
very interesting [ __ ] occupation and
you know that was why I told bang okay I
want to talk to him about because that's
what people at home want to know like
why would I need a strength and
conditioning coach
why can I just work out well cuz you're
a fat [ __ ] and you're not about to go to
the Olympics so you don't need a [ __ ]
strength and conditioning coach when you
decide what you want to do and what your
holes in your game or and then you go
see him and go you know what I'm [ __ ]
terrible with hip escapes and we're
trying to [ __ ] throw people off me
yeah you put a workout for them designed
specifically they have that with the
cardio in the whole [ __ ] and if
people don't feel something like and
that's
what I tell my clients all the time and
some people they show up to me and they
show up to a gym and they're kind of
like in Timoney because they see
everything going on and they think it's
a big deal for them it's it for us it's
normal day first other people come in
it's a big and you always said people
listen it's tough enough to get regular
people to go to 10th planet jiu-jitsu in
Burbank
I mean people watch the UFC so a stigma
goes with it so there's some people
there's a guy next to the Guitar Center
where I used to take tanks you know that
dude they teach Gracie whatever there
it's $180 a month and nobody rolls you
didn't know that
it's called Gracie combatives you get
real hard to do it you get really good
at doing an arm bar in practice and the
technique and stuff but you're not
allowed to roll they don't roll over
there on sunset I do not [ __ ] know I
do not know but the point was that you
know everybody's looking for something
different so if you go into a lake in if
you go into a place and I do silviana
Machida I'm gonna run the [ __ ] out of it
my mind I think I'm gonna get beat the
[ __ ] up you know people want to feel
like they're not gonna [ __ ] die yeah
that's the main thing nobody wants to
die huh and actually you were saying
earlier that you taking off their focus
and you talked along what's going on in
their life and stuff and let's start off
real [ __ ] slowly huh I just want you
to throw the ball ten times huh or jump
up 22 times and even the most muscular
guy which those [ __ ] need you
need oxygen to have those muscles I've
had guys use that you need to do a plank
and on my back it's cuz you've never
held yourself up you're just standing up
doing curls on yes isn't you've never
done a plank in your life you know and
it's amazing it's so crazy what we're
finding out now over the years like when
I first started lifting I used to read
Muscle & Fitness you know to the [ __ ]
tee I loved it I I read about Tom Platts
and all these dudes that dude Mike Mets
the he did 20 sets per body part
so I was like [ __ ] it I'll do it and
that's exactly what I do I love that
night and I [ __ ] him you know but it was
uh I worked myself up into it the people
I lifted with knew a little bit about it
mm-hmm and then I met more people than
the dudes I moved to Colorado it would
strengthen not strength and conditioning
dudes those dudes that do [ __ ]
dentist with cars and they pick up
strong on trends wrong men those two
dudes both the brothers mm-hmm you know
we build racks downstairs and it was
[ __ ] crazy but I remember that they
would print like muscle-bound dudes over
and the muscle-bound dudes couldn't even
move the bar and these guys were doing
it all it was just technique yeah
whether it's jujitsu lifting weights
yeah I was a kid I used to go to Joe
Namath football camp mmm
first make the kids on in a football
camp after you dropped your [ __ ]
clothes off was you or nothing you did
the 40 and they time you pick you know
why am i doing the [ __ ] voice well
every day before breakfast is a
30-minute workout and all they did was
you was extend your legs kick out like
thinking you're a [ __ ] Nazi like
you're one of those Russians that do
that the ghoul off dance with you that's
all you did you do this and you kick
your legs out that's how you had a run
look at me Lee okay so you gotta run
like this right so you have to kick your
leg out and you did say you stretch then
you did something else at the end of the
week are you ready do the 40 beep and
awesome they tell you what your speed
wasn't your way what happened the guy
goes we broke down your mechanics and we
pre-programmed you you just pick them 2
seconds on your time or some [ __ ]
because it was all mechanics it's all
you ever seen D'Agostino wiper I know
watch the Agostino why Fred she's
Russian she runs
perfectly on point you look at here you
go oh [ __ ] that's what you're supposed
to look like these [ __ ] people
running killing themselves because in
Russia they teach how to March
they teach how to walk they teach how to
[ __ ] run they teach how to do all
that [ __ ] when you're kids where there's
no misunderstandings they teacher the
[ __ ] basics grow when you see her
it's a thing of beauty in Vegas one time
I went to the gym and she was in the gym
working out cuz D'Agostino is a comedian
and she came with him and she was just
running he tells me she'll get up at
4:00 run for miles so when you see her
form like I didn't brought I lived in
Boulder I've seen all those people and
I've never seen anybody rolling yet I'm
never seen it's perfect it's a thing and
when you see it you'll go wow they
really do a good job and Russia
well the [ __ ] is hotter and it's perfect
her arms don't go high they come up to
like here and you go oh my god that's
the mechanic of the run yeah what what
speaking of that what do you see or what
do you think when you see someone don't
like bad form and when we were talking
about baseball there's a bunch of people
who've done it but on the Red Sox there
used to be a picture called beyond young
Kim anyway sidearm and I like I just
imagine his elbow like snaps every third
week or something like when you see that
do you get upset I mean the the thing is
what we do to men is we break it down
there's one thing between skills and
then training so like the skills work we
work we we bring in a lot of the best
coaches like that to work with our guys
on skills work and then we do a lot of
like their strength training to building
to work with these guys because we know
man that that's two different two whole
different things because like that
because with like how byung-hyun kim
throws right there is people who like to
throw sidearm and whatever it is but if
you'll find a way the strength in that
arm yeah so they won't [ __ ] it up and
continue to yeah so we work we work with
the pitching coaches we work with their
skill specific coaches because man do
you know how it is in coaching or
whatever it is anything but everybody's
got a attitude everybody wants to show
that there's a big dick whatever it is
so we're like nothing that cubed nine
this way nope okay cool I saw no beside
thank you but I didn't know especially
when you're dealing with that time Miami
everybody's a play for the Cuban
national team and your walkie and this
and that yeah everybody there's a guy in
a park with a bad doing all types of
[ __ ] but like that man it's uh it's it's
we work with those guys because there's
there's so much more room off the field
to do [ __ ] because man when I was I was
trying to get better all stuff I was
deadlifting I was putting up a [ __ ] ton
away getting stronger [ __ ] protein
shakes everything but my fastball stayed
the same everything that I was doing on
the field I'm like [ __ ] I'm not getting
better I'm getting little what the [ __ ]
is happening like I'm training I'm doing
this [ __ ] every day but if you're what
you're doing in training and in the gym
isn't benefiting what you're doing
outside like whatever your goal is
whether it's being a [ __ ] executive
and walking better and your back not
hurting or trying to throw a 100 mile an
hour fastball it's that what the [ __ ]
you doing what are you doing what's the
whole purpose what are we doing here
you're just sitting here throwing up
weights wasting your time like it's
great to look good it's great to run
fast it's great toilet ship but if you
can't do what you're doing then what do
we got like you know so that's that's
the whole thing especially with with
anybody so that's why we work with these
guys hand-in-hand close so they tell us
say this person sucks at this whatever
it is that we train when we when we
train some of the USC guys you know like
we we we know what they're doing we know
exactly what's going on so we we try to
work with them not necessarily against
these guys cuz every every pro athlete
everybody has a coach already from
somebody growing up they're all know
I've had this close since I was 12 I've
had in this coach the social good cool
I'm glad I love the stuff you're doing
cuz it got you to this point yeah I
don't not hear the changes yeah I'm here
to strengthen what we got yeah and get
your weaknesses six weeks I'm not gonna
[ __ ] make you Demian Maia and six
[ __ ] weeks but I'll teach you
how to not get submitted yeah by a
triangle this data low mulatto I'll
teach you all the defenses and you just
get the [ __ ] up and run away yeah that's
it get up and run away to the other side
of the cage yeah no come back for that
second camp and then it's a whole
different game boom the game you don't
know what to see if you if you watch
some of those 3430
those things they'll tell you how they
went to a certain football program and
they were quarterback but they try to
make him a wide receiver and then they
got the kids got no career because the
coach you know uh Jamie Foxx in that
movie that went to Miami maybe when he
got into it with the what's-his-name
that's what we told him because you know
why I went in the third round because
that dumb [ __ ] coach my freshman year
made me a DB instead of a [ __ ]
quarterback because he said I would have
been a better DB and I would have played
you don't do that to people
yeah you don't do that to people you
take their strengths it's like if I'm 13
and Oh in the UFC with knockouts and 11
of them have been with this [ __ ] left
hand you're not gonna come to me and go
dog we got to start [ __ ] curling and
doing what our imposes left hand is fine
don't bother nobody mind your business
let me just wash out out get the [ __ ]
out Italy are you feeling beautiful hey
you're making noises
you ain't how many edibles three you
really went low to all-time low mm mm
Jay Paul the way you did bring the ones
Italian I thought you were gonna eat
these coconut things I mean they taste
delicious
you know but then I saw you brave brave
Ivan it just broke my heart I couldn't
do it anymore
I try but I couldn't do it anymore Don
Rangel you know I love you Tyler Obie
westwoods Danny beyond cool oh my old
friend Savage Lindsay LaForge Kanye West
Alice Quinton tarantella Georgie Clark
Owens Perry and Joe Devlin you know I
love you [ __ ]
I made some famous listeners for a
second again next week the Ontario
improv Thursday Friday and Saturday
tickets are available knock yourself the
[ __ ] out you understand me well I'm back
you got your hair up tonight's looking
good Becky had a boyfriend a few weeks
ago she doesn't think I know
they tied her up and [ __ ] they do a lot
of nasty things too but she looks good
that's all that matters that's great how
are your legs doing Becky are they
[ __ ] things yes the son of those
goddamn things if yellow bow hit you a
little bit yeah it's funny like we're
talking about earlier how all the Cubans
and the finding each other especially
out here in that lay man it's it's just
it's crazy how it is how life takes you
places and like you just I'm how I met
Becky like through a mutual friend and
all of a sudden man a maybe I might move
out here and boom on with some we're
friends and then oh I know you're Cuban
all the stuff and it's just like man how
how we always end up finding each other
because there's not that many Cuba's
spread out there's a lot of us but we're
we're gonna like in concentrated areas
like that like you know it's it's it's
funny how life works when you're gonna
be really surprised you know we were
talking about people who don't leave
their neighborhoods and I got nothing
against you
people like if you you know I grew up
with a thousand people who go to Florida
once a year and then lattic City the
other side of the year and that's what
they've done for the last 40 years and
that's what they're gonna do till they
die guys they don't want to go out to
California's a lot of crazy people out
there and yeah all those yka do is out
there people walking around naked my
nephew tell me that would people walk
around naked not you know are you scared
of earthquakes people hit me with that
all my comedy though it's kind of weird
but in real life you'd be very surprised
what happens when you do go out of your
comfort zone you pick up your bags and
you give life a try and that's the
people have never realized I don't
realize that an early age the cops are
looking for me is wrong with the
Sarasota Florida and I met 15 people and
other 15 people in the head of them
offering me jobs and three of them
offered me places to live
Wow and if you move here you could go to
this Beach with us on Saturdays you know
nothing happens again do you leave the
couch well if you want to stay on the
couch you're never gonna mean nobody
nothing's gonna happen you know when you
put those wheels in motion
you know you might meet somebody who
mugs you you might say [ __ ] I'm gonna
take a bus out to California with the
last 8,000 my god
I'm gonna get an apartment Joey told me
there's an apartments by his house you
you can land on the [ __ ] Saturday I'm
out of town I can't pick you up you're
down to you this way you get mugged you
know you get like a hit in the head and
also some chick walks by and takes you
to a house and make sure you never know
what could happen until something
happens something you see the beauty of
people and what's really out there yeah
you know what the [ __ ] is really out and
what do you really have to lose man just
by making a decision like the smallest
thing just by saying what's up to
somebody and just like man this monster
it's crazy how many people don't
understand you know what I Love New York
said with the Colorado people say good
morning to me you away were you driving
would wave and say good morning I would
go that apartment and yell at my
roommates what the [ __ ] lazy saying good
morning to me whether you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I think I am it was a different
thing it throws you off it would throw
it would throw me off they would it
really would man I was from New York and
people don't talk to each other in the
mom they just look at the floor and walk
straight ahead now people making eye
contact on good morning uh how is your
day going what you okay I don't even
know you
is your business growing in Colorado
they used to hit when I first moved to
be strong in 1983 you know I was raised
you don't get a nobody's got and when I
was 14 15 one time I got somebody's car
he felt my dick then kind of door
opening I read he did he had a
basketball between my legs and he asked
me if I liked playing basketball he went
at the basketball he's purposely let his
hand slip then he touched my dick I was
14 there was 22 feet of snow and then
God was in the [ __ ] car cuz the door
mysteriously open and I ran out and I
ran behind the car into the sexual but
this [ __ ] German Park
what the [ __ ] it's in park and I
[ __ ] he made a u-turn and went in
there looking for me come back yeah I
was gonna report him he was writing away
man I said I'm never going to nobody's
car well here I am five years later if
you're walking on route 82 from Glenwood
Springs
the aspen people will pull over their
shoe Hey
how far you going you're like [ __ ] you
I'd be like [ __ ] yo [ __ ] [ __ ]
pervert
and then when their woman picked me up
and that was you on the ride I was like
oh [ __ ] and at that time it HBO's Big
Show was the hitchhiker
it came on at night about a good-looking
hitchhiker that could go out and women
would pick him up then he'd take him
back to this [ __ ] log cabin he [ __ ]
up his [ __ ] they wouldn't show his
bigger [ __ ]
did you show up at going like this and
him looking at away then they'd show
dragons penis and looking up bleep look
up the hitchhike on HBO circa 1980 see
if they have the with you see you going
around Colorado no I didn't say that I
said that when the woman picked me up
that day that's what my daughter the
[ __ ] hitchhiker
that EE listen another time my car blew
up in the braska Nebraska's dance one
time I was in Ocala Nebraska and I'm
[ __ ] the frame broke on the car I was
coming back from Michigan the [ __ ]
frame broke it's got two flat tires one
after the other paw and then the other
bus so I figure out the frame broke he
kept rubbing against the tires and make
them blow up so [ __ ] this chick pulls
over oh my god didn't have a bra but
just to share you could see the Sun you
can see a little baby Tenney's she's yet
she had no shoes on and she had on pin
here which sent me over the top I'm like
this lady's an animal little let me kill
him she'll leave me money for kill me
what is that squirrel down there these
right there which one ten years ago you
see an intro the hitchhiking up there
you go you you just did there
look at the [ __ ] always go back
to my place I'll just leave them there
[Music]
it's Cupid they look a CD so that it'll
show it see but that was it oh [ __ ]
that's like that's like a Cuban thing
man I've always heard that like even
growing up you're not a man until you
eat someone's ass that's what those used
to grab us deliver a prize say it on
stage the first time I heard it what are
you talking about was a man like Sutan
but serious talks though serious time
was about five then in your real woman
Becky well that was about five I was
watching TV Tuesday nights
my mother would play cards with four
like you were warmer than one chick that
was Cuban Chinese la cheese and they
would play cards until this bad all over
this lady's name
my goal something my husband had just
gotten out of jail they play cards on
Tuesday night and stay up all night I'm
Duffy I was doing some watching TV and
my mother was on the phone and she was
bitching to my mother in front of me
then let me tell you what that son of a
[ __ ] did to me last night last night
Seconal old meal my mother will a papaya
he fell asleep sucking my [ __ ]
what kind of man that she's talking to
my mom I was like I wanna hear my throne
now you falsely beat my butcher sitting
there watching cartoons like how these
two [ __ ] savages talking about I'll
never forget her telling my mom that the
[ __ ] fell asleep how do you fall
asleep I would never fall sleep in
somebody's [ __ ] just sniffing that
little caffeine from that monkey keep
you up for 24 hours of [ __ ] but like
that didn't know that little monkey got
caffeine and gunpowder come from the
coffee and so do you drink whatever I
don't know I'm not saying we it's a
[ __ ] joke I said I'm just saying that
nah some place is no joke man well I'm
telling you like one time I was there
with a few of my buddies like that and I
his friend is his dad comes in he said
hey guys are gonna talk to you eight you
guys yeah like that's right he goes you
guys want a girl too I remember you
brought like that girl's ass I'm like
come on bro he's like he's like no
problem being dead ass serious like that
you're just like bro what the [ __ ]
you're like 11 12 years old you'll be
like what the [ __ ] I pull my [ __ ]
mom's friend gave me a little vial of
coke and told me next time my skinny
girlfriend came over and put some
coconut [ __ ] I'm like what are you
talking about and I held that coke like
six months on my draw I put it in a drug
capsule like I took a what do you call
those things the cold I've done contact
oh and I emptied it out and they put the
coke in and I put that close and I put
in the back of the drawer so nobody
would know him one day my mother came in
she goes hey man poppy told me something
disturbing that he gave me a coke to put
on that girl's [ __ ] is that true I know
maybe here she goes [ __ ] give that to
me right he is he crazy and are you
[ __ ] crazy so I gave my mom little
capsule with the coconut cheese mother
yeah because when I went to Catholic
school there was a guy my mother's bar
they would say to me
they suck your dick down at that
Catholic school and I would look at him
and go what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
it's a boy school eagle so what he goes
just let him suck your dick it's a party
you don't have to suck their dick and I
would like no no no like the other kids
Oh like he would goof on me and go and
then one day he told me a [ __ ] once
suck my dick his mouth was cold
never forget that was a young yeah I was
like [ __ ] 12 and he was telling me
let me tell you something no big deal
yeah it's like my dick good night we
might even party money calm them all up
in were legit they all walk out free
yeah there's nothing off limits you walk
into the room like when I was a little
kid I'll show me whenever they'll be
like oh yeah booyah leche I'm like bro
come on they break you down as a kid so
that when you get older that's it man
you're ready for whatever cuz people
know man you're gonna get taken
advantage of they like you older adult
people I've seen it man so they like but
they try to break it yeah I like when
they ask you if you still be a sweet
amazing is still a little [ __ ] kid
once you start business hour that means
that come comes I'll you dick
and then I ask you in front of your
mother like hey you still pissed sweet
go try to embarrass you and ask of you
[ __ ] before everybody's on top of you
and the family parties that's one thing
too as a fact and just in a family
parties man everybody's dancing
everything you're growing up and your
dad's I or whatever it is like go dance
go dance with your grandma go dance with
bears huh call it a lot you just throw
them in and all of a sudden next thing
you know you're dancing in front of the
whole family bro what is it like it's a
whole they break you down like that you
don't get shy in front of anybody you
like you know where to go like that they
tell you don't get into anybody's cars
don't this don't die
yyy boom all of sudden everything
happens yo [ __ ] okay damn bro that makes
sense my mom isn't crazy she knows what
the [ __ ] she's saying like that cuz I
mean as a span like I just at least in
Miami like it's not I don't want to say
that like it's sheltered that better
nice try to keep a shelter book it's
your mom's man your mom keeps you tight
your family keeps you tight close to you
they want to know everything you're
doing especially your span or you're on
the Todd North alakina hey whatever like
you know like it's just it is how it is
man they say hold you tight family is a
[ __ ] great thing to have I haven't
like a Cuban family or any family for
that matter like that site you missed
that yeah that's why I was telling ya
Fred Ricky I used to live out here he
said he loved LA he loved that thing he
loves stand-up but there was times he
couldn't it didn't add up for the he
wanted to be what his family what days
are you down there I'm down there every
day man Sunday through Sunday all day
every day
what kind of we're open by appointment
man so it's like whenever people people
make sessions but I have a lot of people
that like to work in the morning we have
classes going on too
so like I'm always putting that out on
social media and through our website or
whatnot so constantly putting that they
call down there they ask for Rene yeah
Rene is good to go sir yes sir come on
no I appreciate you guys talking about
it well you've got that Lisa I am what
do I got I am the call [ __ ] mummified
come on the very much stronger weed I'm
doing I don't have anything coming up
this weekend I don't think I I went to
the ain't the daughter's game the other
day you talking to the ladies Friday
yeah third time a bit hit me up has been
twice I can surely you think engage no I
like it a lot you thinking water
yes that's good I want to thank [ __ ]
on it for being our sponsor being
[ __ ] savages for being there with us
from day one they got the best shroom
tech sport people [ __ ] breathe for
days on that [ __ ] me it makes my heart
pound out of my shirt I love it a shroom
tack on a cup of coffee and you go do
some jujitsu jesus [ __ ] christ
get some hemp force protein and always
you can't go wrong with the alpha brain
just if you don't like it two hundred
percent money-back guarantee and they
don't even want the [ __ ] product back
so take that to the bank go to church
calms last one on a.com slash church on
it not Thomas last Church can get 10%
off sent right the [ __ ] door you
[ __ ] animals
all right I want to thank Renee one more
time Lisa at Becky and all you
[ __ ] for listening we had a
great week this week see you
[ __ ] Saturday at the ice house
or next week at the Antarian prom stay
black
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you